so I have this I asked you about the
fantasy suites are those day like
back-to-back it's like one day one off
night one night the so is every other so
potentially he could be sleeping with
all the women in the same week yes
should you choose to forgo your
individual rooms tonight please use this
key to stay as a couple in a fantasy
suite do you think that he will do that
Jelena yeah I mean I think a lot of
people do on the show and it's not just
Nick I think a lot I will say that I
didn't um I have said before I only was
intimate with one person because I felt
strongly about um your connection my
connection with that person but I've
also said that out of my top three guys
it was Roberto Chris and Frank Frank
left me um at the top three so if he had
stayed would I have been intimate with
more than one person yes I would have I
mean I would have you know such a
connection yes so yeah so like I didn't
but I'm not saying I wouldn't have and
so and I from talking to the past
bachelor and bachelorettes most do sleep
with the people in the fantasies like I
have a slightly dirty but logistical
question
I remember watching real world and they
used to leave out like bowls of condoms
all over the house like what are the
fantasy suites like with like this is an
Asian really one I don't know because I
don't I don't think I don't remember
honestly and I think that that maybe
they give them to the guys exactly which
is crazy they should give to the girls
too what is going to be their thought
process mindset going into it I'm
genuinely curious appear for feeling
insecure if you're excited if you're
knowing oh this guy's gonna go sleep
with other women the same week that he's
left with me how is that affecting your
your brain I'm The Bachelor I sent
myself home right before sit fantasy
suites I would have gone crazy I would
have lost my mind I think um but on my
season again because I only had two
fantasy suites and one of the guys who's
very nice I would just we didn't have a
connection he'll he'll say the same
thing so I like asked the producer to
call to get me an excuse to leave the
room
[Music]